der kleine ort rot am see bei schwäbisch
hall seit januar steht der für eine
blutige tat fast eine ganze familie
wurde hier bin minuten ausgelöst von ihm
adrian es zu einem familientreffen
erschien er mit einer pistole und
erschoss sechs seiner engsten verwandten
mutter vater zwei halbgeschwister onkel
und tante teilweise mit kopfschüssen
zwei weitere verwandte konnten sich
schwer verletzt retten
heute nun das urteil 15 jahre haft für
den killer von rot am see gleich zum
prozessauftakt hatte der die tat
gestanden da habe ich auf alles
geschossen was sich bewegt hat sagt er
später gab er misshandlung seiner mutter
als motiv für seine tat an
sie habe ihn missbraucht und vergiftet
beweise dafür gab es allerdings während
des prozesses nicht ein psychiater hatte
bei ihm waren vorstellungen eine
krankhafte seelische störung
diagnostiziert adrienn es wird fortan in
einem psychiatrischen krankenhaus
untergebracht
[Musik]